let's think about where we would plot
two sixths on this number line so let's
count what each of these little marks
represent so we have when we're going
between zero and one we have one
two three four five
six of these marks or another way to
think of it is these marks split zero
the the length of our number line
between zero and one into exactly six
equal spaces so this is one of the six
then this is another of the six so that
gets us to 2 6. if we go another one we
get to 3 6. we go another one we get to
4 6 then 5 6 then this is 6 6 which is
the same thing as 1. so to answer our
question where is 2 6 well this gets us
to 1 6 then another 6 gets us 2 2 6. if
someone were to ask you where is 5 6
well that is 1 6 2 6 3 6 4 6 and 5 6. if
someone were to ask you where is three
over six well once again this these and
you have to make sure this is splitting
up the number line to exactly six equal
spaces between zero and one but if you
do then these are each sixth and so you
get 1 6 2 6 and 3 6 and you may or may
not know 3 6 is the same thing as one
half if you divide 3 by 3 and 6 by 3
you're dividing by dividing the
numerator and denominator by the same
thing you get one-half and that makes
sense because this is exactly one-half
of the way between zero and one